[Music]
hey Rich hello greetings hi all right
take two your podcast is a little Beacon
of light every week
Rich it's uh absolute honor and pleasure
to be able to leave a message like this
from the Bronx New York I live in Cody
Wyoming I'm from Philly hence the accent
slang from Atlanta Georgia Calgary
Alberta full Massachusetts I'm actually
running on the treadmill right now
listening to the latest girl on
thank you foreign
I live in Madrid Spain I'm going all the
way from Australia calling you from Abu
Dhabi
and out of Emirates thank you so much
for doing this and giving us the
listeners the opportunity to share our
stories the podcast has not just kept me
company but has given me immense hope
and confidence in the power of subtle
transformation I've been listening to
started
the first episode I've proposition to
over 300 podcasts and it really has
changed my life
the biggest gift that your podcast has
given me is that I shared it with my
daughter Katie she loves it she's
overcome a lot of challenges in her life
and a lot of your guests and information
and books really help her Inspire her to
make changes so it's really been a great
relationship Builder between her and I
we always had a good relationship but
this takes it to another level
every time I listen it just makes me
want to become a better version of
myself
your podcast has really made me think
about what am I doing
um just like when someone said to you
what does your podcast do
it made me think about what I'm doing
uh I know you've been pondering the
question what does your podcast do
um and though I may not be able to tell
you what your podcast does I can tell
you what your podcast does for me
provides inspiration not only through
your own story but to the vulnerable way
in which you tell it what does your
podcast do such a simple question
it changes lives it changed mine and
implanted values and lessons
what does your podcast do it inspires
peace desires and fans the flame to our
intuitive fires
what does your podcast do
they plant seeds pulls weeds and does
Good Deeds
what does your podcast do it shifts
perspectives gives directives and casts
light toward the dark and neglected
at the end of last year we debuted a new
format for this show with an episode
dedicated to compilations of stories
sent in by our listeners
the result was an incredible achievement
that showcased the talent the drive the
perseverance and the inspiration of the
amazing humans that comprise the RRP
community
if you haven't listened to that episode
yet I highly encourage you to do so but
this year we decided to do it again and
after putting out a call for more
stories and curating the best responses
we're super proud to present to you
profits Walk Among Us Part Two
as I said in last year's episode this
show is and has always been for and
about you the listener without you the
conversations that make up the bulk of
this show just don't move the needle and
lies beyond my own
is the true impact of this platform is
inspiring positive change in the lives
of people within and and beyond our
community in other words
you matter to me it's why I do what I do
and what follows is your voice this is
your community these are your stories
and I can't wait to share them all with
you right now
hello greetings this is
Brown from Atlanta Georgia
I want to say thank you for sharing your
truth on the podcast
I am a new listener and I find your
platform authentic inspiring and
enriching your message of self-love and
nurturing of community for the greater
good resonate so deeply and is beyond
refreshing you are truly a soul brother
my friend
I find that though we are from different
cultures we speak the same truth I am
Nigerian by birth and started listening
to your Show recently and some of the
words that you use in the language that
you use are so rich and so similar uh to
what I say every day and so without a
doubt you are elevating the individual
and Collective Consciousness with your
work May the universe continue to
conspire to light your path and fill
your heart with joy and abundance
in 2015 I was morbidly obese so I took
up walking
and I strolled while listening chair
podcast and imbued my trucks with
purpose feeding and need people on the
streets of Toronto with homemade vegan
sandwiches
and crazily I lost 100 pounds
I've walked hiked and ran more than 62
000 kilometers by foot across six
continents as well as completed 600
freestyle marathons listening to Rich
and Adam and all your wonderful guests
along the way your pod really has kept
me company on my tracks as well as
inspired me when the going gets tough on
hundreds of marathons
and I just want to let you and the
listeners know that I'm proof positive
that having this positive combos
continually piped into your ears over
years and years can really power some
unbelievable outcomes and this really
can't be understated anyway I'm about to
dedicate all of 2023 to Breaking the
Guinness world record for most marathons
in a year which is more than 240 which
I'm choosing to do solo this means no
support crew and across 50 to 100
different countries to up the ante and
I'll definitely be an art and listener
next year as I really need the wind in
my sails once again when the going gets
top
foreign
[Music]
I um
just listened to the first installment
of listeners stories and in true fashion
I'm coming in late but it doesn't matter
because I'm coming in and I'm showing up
that is just one of many lessons I've
learned through
your podcast so
my story
eight years ago I moved from Rhode
Island
to Spain and a big Catalyst for that was
my mother's drinking
single parent only child
my grandma helps as much as she could
but my mother was just dealing with
wretched childhood drama
through immigration to the point where I
mean I don't think she's functioning
but heart-wrenching and it seems like
it's just what an emergency after
another
motorcycle accident
house fire
hospitalization just I mean searing
anxiety for me
I didn't officially quit college but I
wasn't going for a year
managed to get out of all of that and I
moved to Spain I needed distance and
it's taken even longer to learn about
emotional distance and because it's been
so normalized it took until a tenant of
my mom's house that she bought to tell
me
your mom is unconscious on the stairs
and going to the hospital because she's
an alcoholic sweetie
and um I just I was shattered
and it took me a long time to separate
from
all of the entangled feelings that came
with my mother's pain from her past and
that her only way of dealing with it was
from drinking
but I found this podcast I had already
started running a few years ago it's
just such a great channel for emotions
and I've been able to find my identity
and no longer just observes but rather
do
through examples and
thoughtful conversations about
resilience and Temperance and
faith and trust through your podcast so
thank you and really I can I can find my
identity apart from my mom's suffering
and I don't drink anymore life is good
I feel absolutely with it and I think
what I've learned through your show and
I just learned this yesterday through
your show in and through life of course
through doing these hard things is that
um
but I'm stronger than pain I've
been my own pain I'm stronger than that
and
I can always love
and
thank you for what you do a million
times over peace plants are Namaste
friends
[Music]
hello my name is Will Toca uh you guys
took my call over a year ago it was the
nft episode that you guys did for on the
Roman episode I just wanted to know if
you guys had any advice on on starting
over uh for for folks who have kind of
lost it all I was overweight my father
had passed away and I was in a slump I
ended up in the hospital diagnosed with
type 2 diabetes A1C of 11.1 and had a
bad infection
I remember the advice you guys gave me
and it really kind of resonated with me
when I was kind of in bed and just
dealing with the infection and getting
ready to make a plan I remember rich
said this enemy that you're facing is
comparing yourself to this person that
you were seven years ago comparison is
the thief of Joy so stop comparing
yourself to your past self or to other
people it's not about that it's not
about training where you think you
should be it's about accepting and
embracing where you are right now and
doing what you are capable of doing
because that's the only way that you get
anything done or make any progress so it
started with eating right getting rid of
all the food that got me in this place
and also walk into the mailbox taking
the dog around the block and a walk
became a jog and a dog became a run I
tapped into the advice you guys gave me
I took it a day at a time a step at a
time little decisions Little Steps made
big big big outcomes uh and I want to
thank you guys so much I had my check up
two months ago and I dropped I got my
A1C down to 5.3
doing my third half marathon in October
and I want to thank you guys again for
not only giving me the tools to do
things physically but emotionally as
well and really work on that part of me
as well as the other stuff it truly is
true when you say mood follows action
and it ensure that thank you guys for
everything you do
stream chronic
chronic I had been an avid cyclist and
was working for an active travel company
planning bike tours in Europe when I got
sick almost overnight I went from
healthy and active to unable to walk
upstairs on my own after a month of
going to doctors barely able to function
I was diagnosed with Epstein-Barr and
chronic fatigue syndrome I found that my
well-meaning doctors had little to offer
in terms of treatment or hope of
recovery and I was even recommended that
I accept my new limitations and perhaps
get a wheelchair to make life easier
needless to say it was extremely
frightening and depressing I decided
that I needed to believe in something
different that I could recover and I set
out to figure out how it was in my dive
into healing health and nutrition that I
found your podcast
over the last five years your podcast
has influenced my recovery in both
practical and emotional ways you
introduced me to plant-based eating of
course and I changed my diet finding
body aches reduce you introduced me to
Wim Hof and I used his breathing
practices to help my body heal I started
using acupuncture as a powerful part of
my recovery after hearing your
conversations with Colin hudon as well
as Julie's own story of healing a type
of goiter on her neck with the use of
herbs and Eastern medicine but it was
hearing your own story of recovery rich
as well as the story of so many of your
guests all overcoming adversity that
gave me a sense of hope and
determination listening to your podcast
helped me see my situation as an
opportunity for growth and something I
would be grateful for one day I saw
getting through my challenge as my ultra
endurance race
I'm happy to report that five years
later I'm back on the bike what's more I
quit my job in January of 2020 and
enrolled in a four-year master's program
in acupuncture and traditional Chinese
medicine
my goal is to help others to kill
personally misunderstood chronic illness
deciding to make such a pivot at age 41
was daunting but knowing that you
completed your first endurance race at
42 helped me to see that it's never too
late to make a big change
Rich oh man there are so many ways in
which you've influenced my life let me
throw out number one on the short list
mood follows action
your Mantra has helped me see many
obstacles sitting between me and the
life I've wanted to live over the past
two years
in the interest of time I'll give you
one example ever since I read The
Outsiders in seventh grade mind you I'm
now 51 years old I wanted to write a
novel I've had flashes of inspiration
and ideas for plots and characters over
the years but always told myself once I
get through acts accomplish why perhaps
Z in the bank I'll pursue my dream well
a number of factors converged two years
ago that led me to leave my career in
finance
as I did the responsible thing and began
networking from a next job the little
boy and me kept raising his hand started
talking back then ultimately shouted
stop waiting around to feel ready to
write that book just start writing so we
can all feel better
so I started then covet hit by then the
action of getting started had triggered
such an avalanche or positive vibes that
a day hasn't passed since when I haven't
worked on my book about growing up
making mistakes tragedy running and
Recovery as I leave you this message I'm
giving the manuscript for Beyond Spirit
Hill a final read through thank you and
stay tuned
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Trails tells tales and provides wind for
ourselves
what does your podcast do it eats plants
hosts chants and gives the underdog a
chance
does your podcast do
follows Curiosity has discussions on
philosophy and is the biggest Catalyst
for change in our lives quite possibly
on November 4th of 2021
my four-year-old son was diagnosed with
heart failure
and admitted to the hospital where he
waited for transplant and while we were
waiting his heart was so bad that he had
to be hooked up to a machine to help his
heart beat for about seven months until
he got his transplant
and during that time you know I had been
an avid listener to the podcast and I
took a lot of the lessons that I had
learned through what I've learned
through Endurance Sports through running
and mental toughness into that
experience
when you're waiting for a heart you
don't have any idea if you're going to
be there for six weeks or 18 months and
having a three-year-old at home and my
four-year-old in the hospital it was
really trying between going back and
forth and our family being separated and
I was shocked at how many of the lessons
that I took from endurance training and
running
seemed to translate on the long nights
when
we didn't know what was on the other
side of the coin while we were waiting
and really I just wanted to say thank
you so much to this podcast for uh
giving me the mental toughness and
strength and lessons that I needed to
get through that time
Jake is now five years old almost six
actually on December 20th and doing
great and we are enjoying all the
pre-Christmas activities
and having a great time and we're so
grateful to the Children's Hospital here
that got us through and I personally am
very grateful to this podcast which was
really the thing that got me through
thank you so much
I discovered your podcast about nine
years ago I needed something to listen
to while training for an Ultra and your
show came on and I downloaded an episode
not knowing the impact it would have
at first I listened almost out of kind
of amused sense of curiosity because
I was very much eating a typical Western
diet at that time
maybe even more so in terms of animal
products as I was feeling the whole keto
thing
but after almost two years of listening
to your show
I had suffered an injury to my leg and I
underwent surgery my leg was wrapped in
a calf and I was bedridden for two
months
I wanted to reduce the swelling and I
remembered that you and your guests
talking about how I plant base tie it
reduces inflammation so I switched to it
by eating cows and drinking fruits
smoothies and the most amazing thing
happened
despite being unable to move for two
months I somehow lost weight and when
the cast came off the doctors were
shocked at how much the swelling had
gone down
and that was the proof that I needed to
make the change
since then I've embraced the plant-based
diet
not only for myself but I've seen it
help others as well people like my
teenage son who was struggling with acne
friends with high blood pressure my dad
who had a high PSA and possible prostate
cancer
-face diet has been a huge help to them
all and I owe that to you in this show
and not only is the show help heal my
body it provided me at the tools I
needed mentally as well
because as a result of that injury I was
unable to run again
so I went from crossing the finish line
of an ultra six months later being at
the RPM learning how to walk again
and that was very hard for me it's a
loss of something that I love doing and
more than that it's been the loss of
part of my identity
and I still struggle with it to this day
but it just so happens that right before
my injury you had on the show a guest
named Ryan holiday who was talking about
his book The obstacle is the way
which introduced me to this philosophy
of stoicism and the principles of
acceptance
and to only worry about things that you
can control
and Amor Fati was your fate
have embraced that as well and without
it I honestly don't know how I would
have coped in the years since that
injury
but it's given me a better framework for
life
[Music]
I'm in my mid 50s I'm 55 I grew up in um
New York City
and in the 70s and 80s and was a runner
as from the time I was eight on
growing up and in my adult life I've
experienced a lot of traumas in my life
which then LED
um
I was very busy raising children and
being a single mom to two
boys now men and so I was focusing on
that and I and I actually ran three
marathons in my 30s the Vermont City
Marathon the New York City marathon and
then I hit my 40s and everything fell
apart
um the trauma that I had experienced Hit
me hard and I pretty much lost a decade
of my life I gained a lot of weight I
became dependent on alcohol
um and diagnosed with PTSD and
in a hospital and that was about four
years ago and I changed my lifestyle
altogether I became vegan and
I got back right into exercising again
um I'm a runner and a swimmer and a
biker and your podcast inspires me so
much to continue following my dreams and
following my athletic Endeavors which
provide me with relief from depression
and anxiety
and also offer me just an amazing way of
experiencing this world
thank you
rich it is so good to call into your
podcast
I'm an army officer calling from the
Fort Bragg area
and although I've been an endurance
athlete since high school and college
and have been plant-based for two years
my journey of transformation did not
truly begin until just over a year ago
when my mom
killed herself on July 12
2021.
leaving me heartbroken without parents
or in a media family
grief was hard for me
especially as I was juggling in it while
doing an overseas move and starting a
new job path
however
I truly believe the universe conspires
to help us if we let it
because this past December
I began to crawl out from underneath the
tragedy and Trauma when I told some
friends that I would train for a
triathlon this spring
and days later while on a date with a
woman who's now my fiance I was
introduced to your podcast and it has
been a constant companion and guide
from Lisa Miller I learned to lean into
the opportunity that grief provides to
deepen one spirituality
and Alexi Pappas I found solace in her
story of an almost identical trauma
and she gave me insight into trauma
being an injury to the brain
she inspired me to put actions first and
the thoughts will follow
she voiced many of the thoughts
questions and concerns that I had about
my mom
while she talks about hers
lastly Susan Kane
offer encouragement for me to continue
turning my pain into something beautiful
which has led me to continuing to work
on a poetry book
rich in all of your conversations you're
reminded me of the power of human agency
and the power of belief every day I
choose to be grateful every day I choose
hope I choose life because although
existence is full of pain and heartbreak
and suffering we cannot throw up our
hands and succumb to nihilism we must
believe in ourselves we must choose hope
for our futures we must choose the
vulnerability of loving another despite
the fact that we can lose them at any
moment and we must choose life
thoughts follow actions and the best
training bike is the one in the corner
collecting dust
now I've completed three triathlons one
being a half Ironman
I've bought a house
and I'm engaged
the universe inspired
Thank you Rich for all that you do and
for all that you provide to us through
your podcast
bye for now
hello to everyone at the ritual podcast
I'm Sierra Winters I'm 23 years old
originally from North Carolina and I've
been listening to the podcast for a
little over five years and it was one of
the influences that helped me go vegan
at 18. the voices of rich and his guests
have been with me over countless
training runs and indoor rides inspiring
me to keep taking that next step
listening to guests think about the
inner spiritual power of sport and diet
as opposed to the typical weight loss
narrative has helped me overcome my own
struggles with my body as a young woman
it has also helped me remember that
while triathletes can be obsessive
sport is a means to self-improvement of
the inner personality and that my
identity is not the athlete
hearing from people who have traveled
the world and dissolved their identities
as they learn more about the greater
meanings in life has also helped me as I
have moved to India I live there now
with my husband and the cultural shocks
seem to be never-ending but now I see
them as opportunities for growth I see
them as stepping stones to becoming my
strongest self someone who can selfishly
support others without all the Comforts
of a western lifestyle
and this podcast has definitely played a
significant role in developing that kind
of Outlook
all right so my story
um is I used to be a mess before I
hadn't paid my taxes from like 2008 to
2019. I was doing a bunch of drugs I was
starting to do too much cocaine you know
drinking all of that all the bad habits
and I I really needed to turn my life
around so what I did in 2019 early 2019
is I went to a vipassana retreat and
this transported my life and as I came
out of the repositment retreat somehow
ritual came along in my life and carried
me through the last three or four years
since which has been the best years of
my life uh like I said I wasn't there
before and I went in 2019 I decided to
start running when I came out of the
vipassana because I couldn't afford to
pay a gym membership so I said [ __ ] it
you know I'll just run
so I didn't know what to expect but I
ended up really enjoying running I still
run today so I went so I'm like not
running being a couch potato to running
the New York City marathon in 2019 at
the raise like five thousand dollars in
order to run the marathon which was an
amazing experience and then I ended up
doing a triathlon I did an Iron Man I
did a backyard Raceway this year which I
did 114 kilometers and 17 hours
and I'm currently training for another
Marathon so it's been a blessing and I
could go on and on but yeah the podcast
has really inspired me
um and in the end
what I take away from it is that mood
really does follow action thanks to your
control
[Music]
perhaps actually begins because the
sound of my voice right now it is
scratchy because I'm a public high
school English teacher and I've been
reading Of Mice and Men with my 10th
graders and lost my voice
um I'm also a plant-based Runner of
Ultras and
mother and a survivor of trauma which
you've presented in your most recent two
podcasts that I've listened to but a
wide array of your podcasts have changed
my life and transformed me
um but when I was 15 I walked home from
school with a friend and we were
approached out of nowhere by a complete
savior with a gun who threatened Our
Lives
abducted us and sexually assaulted me
and that trauma uh well the changes did
not happen overnight they took decades
but that trauma
changed me
for better and worse or maybe I should
say for worse and then for better
um and your podcast has been a part of
that transformative Journey
um I now do a run to support the
students that I teach every year at
Louisa County High School most recently
in the spring of 2022 I ran from my high
school to Washington DC without stopping
105 miles I was on The Today Show it got
quite a bit of press but I've actually
done runs like that for the last seven
years to raise money for students who
have overcome obstacles
in their lives and that all goes towards
scholarship funds for those students
again your podcast has been
transformational it's supported me in my
plant-based lifestyle you've helped me
in all kinds of ways with my running I
wasn't even a runner until I was 35.
your most recent podcast have been very
very valuable to me as I've continued to
explore my experiences growing up in
therapy but also on my own in many ways
and I just want to thank you so much
hey Rich Steve Proctor in Hawaii the
podcast in your book uh inspired me to
go to my first teacher training which
was in Hawaii
and from that point on I became a yoga
teacher and had taught hundreds of
thousands of people in the Buffalo area
because of that first training which I I
just credit partially towards the
podcast of giving me that push also from
the podcast as you know it led me to
start the November project Buffalo
chapter
um your podcast with DG was the Catalyst
for me to say yes and I did that for
five years and your podcast over the
years is a staple for me to stay in the
work both my parents have gone through
and still going through cancer
treatments and having your eclectic uh
people on the podcast has given me that
ability to have something in my life
that is consistent I look forward to it
every Monday and when I receive
something from your podcast it helps me
give out to my family into the world and
so I know it sounds silly but the
podcast has had a huge impact on me from
Yourself Rich of being such a incredible
person and then all of you genuine
guests have just helped me continue to
be a student of Life which allows me to
share that into the world and make a
direct impact
so your podcasts have made a huge
difference in my life which has impacted
so many others
[Music]
foreign
back in 2017 my husband and I were
taking a road trip and we were listening
to the a recent episode of uh your
interview your first interview with
Bruce Friedrich the executive director
of the good food Institute and at the
time I had recently left a 13-year
career in pharmaceutical sales and I was
looking to find work that was more
meaningful and aligned with my values
and something I could do that would make
a positive impact on the world and when
I heard about GFI and its theory of
change working to make alternative
proteins more accessible more affordable
and more delicious I was sold I was just
convinced I was like this is what I want
to be doing I love the theory of change
of this organization and I want in so as
a result of hearing Bruce interviews on
your podcast I applied to the good food
Institute and it took me a couple of
times times
because the the job openings uh didn't
exactly align with my skill set right
away but in July of 2018 I was hired by
the organization and since then I've
been working with brilliant kind
compassionate people to improve the
future of food and I owe that to the
ritual podcast I don't think I ever
would have learned about GFI or at least
not as early as I did without hearing
Bruce interviewed on uh on your show so
thank you so much for opening my eyes to
the fact that this organization exists
and I'm thrilled to be doing meaningful
work that aligns with my values and I
just want to express my very deep
gratitude for
helping me find this work and for all
you do keep up the amazing work you are
a gift to this world
what does your podcast do
it harnesses pain releases shame and
readjust our lens to a new frame
what does your podcast do it reads books
loves to cook and has a knack for
knowing where to look
what does your podcast do it takes
inventory redefines glory and unpacks
the every person's story
I've always loved running
ever since I was young even in
elementary school it was my passion it
was where I solved problems where I cope
with stress it really allowed me to stay
in super physical condition it was just
what I loved and what I really enjoyed
and it got me to healthy foods in the
diet
in fact on one run in Fort McMurray
Alberta I was face to face with a large
black bear on the Run luckily it went
away well in 2017 I was diagnosed with a
weird disease called Parkinson's disease
I was 60 years old and noticed I was
starting to get Tremor and rigidity on
my right side
and was worried but I still was running
even though it kind of was a weird gate
well as the years went by I struggled
more and more to run up to that point
I'd run over 45 marathons and Ultra
marathons and just new running was What
mattered most well eventually in 2020 I
realized I can't run anymore what can I
do but I realized as you always said
Rich mood follows action I had to adapt
I had to change I had to transform
myself and I think your podcast
over the years really inspired me to do
that and make a difference I decided you
know what you can ride your bike your
road bike or your mountain bike you can
go hiking
you can go to the gym you can work out
lift weights there's other stuff you can
do to make a difference you still feel
strong and healthy and your podcasts
have always inspired me to continue to
do that to try different things even
though I can't run anymore I can still
do these other things and it really has
transformed my life
greetings from suburbs of Yellowstone
Park I first came across you rich when I
did a Google search for authors who had
written their story
I devoured Finding Ultra and started
listening to the podcast and I'm happy
to say that I too visit the rooms and
sit at the table and tell my story of
recovery it's been a long 30-year
journey in and out and right now I am
all in I intend to stay this way one day
at a time thank God
my Ministry and mission in life revolves
around the Desmond Tutu quote we
shouldn't just be pulling people out of
the river we should be going Upstream to
find out what's pushing them in
I've created a life for myself doing
what I love for a living which enables
me to be standing at the place where our
fellows may be thinking of jumping in
the river I teach yoga to all ages at a
little Studio here in Cody I teach art
classes to kids because the local school
district just cut the Elementary art
program last year
I feel for me anyway that yoga and my
own creativity has saved my life time
and time again a beam that has woven in
and out of your podcast throughout the
years
I want to share this with as many people
young and old and in between so as to
help people learn to cherish their minds
their bodies and their Spirits as well
as cherishing others
and I know from you rich with
consistency in showing up in 10 years
from now I will have made a difference
and people will stop jumping in the
river and people will stop drowning
I consider you my great teacher and
guide ritual
we are Kindred in spirit and I can't
even find the language appropriate to
express my deepest appreciation for what
you do how you live and the work you do
foreign
being able to see your Lighthouse your
podcasts your truth
your transparency your vulnerability has
helped me become who I am considering
that it took about 50 years to discover
who I am and I'm currently 53 years old
it's one of those things that you can
never ever imagine that somebody
that you've never met or know from afar
could have such a lasting impact the way
you have on me because for most of my
life I coasted for most of my life I
just flew by the seat of my pants yes
there were times where I had to put the
pedal to the metal yes there were times
that I avoided a lot of different
behaviors patterns and habits that were
crippling me as a human being the people
that I heard along the way
a marriage the first marriage that
failed
in part because of the way I behaved and
the way I didn't take control of myself
of my situations at that time
and to think
between 45 and 50 was such a rough
stretch internally emotionally
psychologically spiritually that I had
to be able to put all my cards on the
table I had to be able to push whatever
it was not necessarily aside because I
didn't want to avoid it but to push all
of the doubt that I had all of the
inferiority that I had about myself
and all the issues that have been
accumulating over the years from being a
child to teenagers young adults to
adults and through my own self-discovery
and obviously through the podcast and
all the wonderful guests that you've had
I've been able to break out through the
other side but as we all know and like
you say best there is no Finish Line I
must continue to persevere because I
want to continue this journey to be on
the right path to success
more so for me internally than it is
externally
and I just want to thank you for all
that you do for all that you've done for
me and I'm sure thousands and thousands
of many other people out there just like
me
[Music]
around the time your podcast started I
found myself diagnosed with an
autoimmune that had no cure and no
treatment and I had been vegan a year
and a half worked out six days a week
just incredibly healthy turned 40. and I
ended up in a wheelchair and I was in
that wheelchair for five years
through a stem cell clinical trial and
got better and all of this has been
since 2012 so
the stories the conversations it's all
just been a guidepost for me to listen
to and be encouraged as I taught myself
to walk again and use my hands and get
out of the chair and
you know re regain life so to speak and
the lessons that I've learned and being
present and
getting through the difficulties and
being told no by world-renowned
hospitals that I'd never get better and
there wasn't any hope
it's just been really uh encouraging to
hear the stories of even though I'm not
an athlete some of these athletes that
have um you know really been told no as
well so I thank you for putting all the
goodness out in the world and um
hopefully my little story will help you
keep going because it does matter
my name is Dan and I'm a 62 year old
pediatrician from Virginia
11 years ago I had a life-altering
accident that rebooted who I am while
body surfing in North Carolina I
suffered a cervical spinal cord injury
that left me limp from the neck down the
universe must have been watching because
strangers saw me and dragged me out of
the water things happened quickly the
helicopter arrived to the closest Trauma
Center multiple tests neck fusion
surgery and then I was parked in the ICU
paralyzed
life can change in a second and that hit
me with a walloping impact that day but
I turned out to be one of the lucky ones
I was an avid cyclist and I think my
level of Fitness helped me out after
four months in the hospital doing
intensive rehab and regain the ability
to feed myself take care of my own bowel
and bladder issues and I gradually
clogged my way back to being able to
walk on behalf with crutches or a cane I
made it my mission to scratch back as
much as I could I was able to return to
work and return to cycling by way of a
recumbent trike
last year I rode 3 500 miles on my trike
always looking for inspiration I read
Finding Ultra and I loved your book the
book and podcast have catalyzed many
changes for me please include a vegan
diet meditation renewed dedication to
exercise and focus on sleep
perhaps the biggest change is that
refocusing of my values I have a much
stronger sense of just how amazing it is
to have this moment of beauty we call a
light on this blue dot floating in the
immense Universe what a miracle your
podcast helps me truly realize what's
important possibility openness curiosity
listening love and gratitude these
values are undergirding my efforts
made me a better person a better father
and husband and a better doctor I see
these drivings and the bright eyes of my
patients in the first Smiles of a
two-month-old to a giggling
five-year-old to a struggling teen who
finally makes a breakthrough and I see
these values in the loving eyes of their
parents thank you rich
[Music]
so I first came across a podcast through
Finding Ultra in 2015. my story is a
little crazy I'm 51 and when I was 26
like Tommy ribs I got laid up in a coma
mine was a different illness a rare
autoimmune immune illness called
vasculitis that attacked my brain I was
in the hospital over two months my heart
stopped a few times is probably a good
thing I don't remember much of it I had
to relearn how to walk talk read write
you name it long story short thank God I
got better but I had a lot of anger she
and his Nile very pretty deep and I
dealt with it the way I knew best
throwing myself into Training Fitness
competitions running making sure I was
so physically exhausted and didn't have
time to deal with what was going on in
my head I'm not proud of some of the
choices I made during that time but I
think about Deborah mate saying trauma
is something that leaves your brain
different than it was before and it
helps me understand and have some peace
nobody talks about mental recovery after
Extreme illness only the physical 25
years ago they didn't anyways in 2015 I
finally decided to face my illness
that's when I came across Finding Ultra
and your podcast I connected with your
journey albeit different you threw
yourself into Ultras when vegan and
recreated your life I went vegan 100
cold turkey that same month
so here's a funny thing that happened
prior to going vegan I'd have vasculitis
flares crazy headaches membrane speech
issues once I went vegan no flare zero
I can't tell you how life-changing
that's been and it's not just a
plant-based lifestyle that's helped me
on my Wellness Journey at Scrabble or
mate about trauma Dr Matthew Walker I'm
sleep Dr BM gut health and Julie on
spirituality and so many more through
the podcast I learned there are so many
elements of Wellness thanks so much
a few years ago I was working kind of at
an agency uh sort of living what I
thought was my dream life as a writer a
lot of parking a lot of not healthy
habits um and I was always listening to
your show but nothing had really stuck
yet and about two years ago I got really
sick and landed in the hospital and
almost died kind of a freak bacteria
thing and when I left the hospital I
kind of felt like you know everything
I'd been giving up to that point was
wrong and I wasn't living the way I
wanted to live
so through listening to your show on a
continual basis I actually picked up
autobiography of a of a yogi which was a
book that Adam's Clinic recommended as
one of his favorite reads and I read
that in the summer and I ended up
signing up for the self-realization
fellowship so now I'm in a really
um deep meditation protocol that I do
every day I quit drinking two months ago
which has been like just amazing in so
many ways and I actually signed up for a
marathon in six months from now
um so you know two years ago at this
point in time I was I was literally you
know on my best bed and I left the
hospital I had to relearn how to walk
again and you know my life has just
changed and all these like really insane
ways and I have to attribute a lot of it
to
um the podcast and I mean I could talk
at length about the different ways that
your show has influenced me in these
really powerful ways but I would say the
takeaway at this point is my life was
totally different I met meditating or
mostly plant-based I don't drink and I'm
running all the time so just trying to
become you apparently
um thanks so much
bye
I've always loved the quote it is no
measure of Health to be well adjusted to
a profoundly sick Society jidu
krishnamurti I remind myself daily that
if I am Guided by my own internal
Compass the universe will inevitably
conspire to provide
my personal growth has been scary
painful uncomfortable in the most
precious and valuable asset I have I've
had to diligently unlearn a way of life
that did not serve me and I won't go
back thanks Rich for being there on long
walks before I broke my knee and being
there to keep the light while I listened
through hours of daily physical therapy
exercises on the living room floor your
wisdom and experience has watered the
seeds of my growth and encouraged me
when others have doubted
I have gone through the worst experience
a parent could my daughter passed away
May 2019 from cancer she had young
sarcoma and she was 11 when she died
[Music]
I've slowly been kind of coming back to
life
um living it again not just
surviving
um still still in survival mode but I
think um coming out of it but
listen to your podcast you know just
reminds me that
I am not the only one going through
something we all have our stories
um some maybe more tragic than others
but everyone's got something and just
hearing their survival and getting
through of in the stories of all the
others and a lot of the psychology and
things like that really just helps me
remember that I'm not alone in this and
um if other people have gotten through
well so can I
um so I just I just wanted to share that
thanks bye
[Music]
I've been a long time listener and I was
drawn to you because of my own trauma
and tragedy that I was so desperately
trying to make sense of
in 2003 our family was involved in a
rollover car accident that left my
strong athletic husband a C5
quadriplegic
[Music]
luckily my kids who were only five and
eight at the time were okay but our
world was turned upside down
we had family and friends walk away and
my health suffered with severe medical
issues that resulted in three major
surgeries and uh finally a diagnosis of
good syndrome a rare immune deficiency
disease
my mom who had been our biggest
supporter got cancer and died very
suddenly and just as I was catching my
breath from that our home burned down in
the horrific car fire
then of course Cove had happened which
was extra difficult being a very immuno
compromised person
[Music]
however all that has led me on the most
important journey of healing and of
trying to make sense of my life trying
to make peace and survive while dealing
with such tremendous pain and grief your
podcast has most importantly tried to
change the story my mind in my mind that
has been replaying and most recently Dr
conti and Dr mate have been huge sources
of knowledge and inspiration your
podcast has given me the tools to go
plant-based and then explore what it
means to be vegan and Rich you've shared
your story and struggle so openly and
with such vulnerability and emotion that
I find myself taking something important
from each guest that has helped in my
life and my road to Healing so as you
can see you've touched my life in so
many ways I'm just so grateful for the
opportunity to share a little of my
story and to hear others as well
[Music]
what does your podcast do it asks
questions suggests introspection cares
from other Earth her inhabitants and
their protection
what does your podcast do it examines
systems of belief serves a dose of
therapeutic relief and finds bitter
sweetness and grief
what does your podcast do
it battles resistance goes the distance
and there's a road map for persistence
it's with my most humble gratitude that
I thank you from the bottom of my heart
for everything and all that you are
thank you for your consistency dear one
and please please keep coming back it's
been an amazing transformation for me
every episode resonates with me love the
conversations keep up the great work and
I thank you for the way that my life has
been transformed as a result thank you
for the chance to express how much this
show has meant to me so I want to thank
you Rich Julie Adam and the whole team
for inspiring me to stay curious and
believe in the possibility of recovery
of all kinds I don't think I could have
done it without you thanks again have a
good one I'm a psychotherapist I'm an
addiction specialist at Kaiser
permanente's addiction medicine
Department in Sylmar California your
podcast is totally inspired me and I use
you constantly for a resource to give to
my people when I do group and when I do
individual therapy and they absolutely
love you you have just you know such a
beautiful thing for all of us to tap
into if there were a badge for a ritual
podcast Super Fan I would probably
display it because I love your show so
much I love sharing it with others the
players never felt posting episodes
because they make my week every week
this was a labor of love for my team it
was a labor of love for me and I'd like
to end this episode in that spirit in
the spirit of gratitude by thanking you
for listening and thanking each and
every one of our callers who submitted
their stories with such vulnerability
with such humility and and Grace because
it's no easy thing to share your
struggles with strangers and I'm just
grateful beyond words for your courage
and for your generosity you have truly
put wind in my sails going into the New
Year and have strengthened my hope in
the goodness of humanity truly but most
of all I want to thank you for letting
me serve because it is in service that I
find purpose that I find meaning and a
sense of deep satisfaction that
positively infuses every aspect of my my
daily life experience
I simply cannot overstate
the extent to which your experiences
humble me
hold me accountable for my own actions
inspire me to do and be better and a
noble meat is Soldier on in the face of
whatever obstacles I may personally face
finally I want to be very clear I in no
way want to take credit whatsoever for
anybody's Journey any improvements our
callers make to their lives are are on
them entirely I just love hearing the
stories it helps me feel more connected
to you and it helps to dry the cement on
this community bond that I'm trying to
Foster because giving back is what it
means to be part of a community thank
you for listening peace
plants
[Music]